et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Sylvain Maillard bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous députés de
Paris vice-président du groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice wesser
Redon du groupe Ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'Est de la France bonjour
on va évidemment parler de la réforme de
retraite nouvelle mobilisation ce
week-end on va y revenir et les
syndicats qui lancent un ultimatum au
gouvernement disons que si le
gouvernement n'entend pas la colère des
Français ils mettront la France à
l'arrêt le 7 mars candidats
je crois que ce serait totalement
irresponsable il y a des discussions
d'ailleurs on continue à discuter avec
les syndicats mais on le redit c'est une
réforme d'effort oui c'est une réforme
où on demande aux Français qui le
peuvent de travailler deux ans de plus
pour équilibrer nos comptes être sûr que
les pensions que notre niveau de pension
qui est probablement le meilleur niveau
de pension qui existe en Europe dont on
est très fier puisse perdurer dans le
temps le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites nous le dit et le redit il n'y
a pas d'équilibre à moyen et long terme
ça veut dire que à la fin ou bien on
augmente les cotisations et donc
réaugmentation du chômage ou bien les
pensions baisseront et le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites nous dit à
échéance 15 ans 20% des cas par rapport
à ce que nous avons à l'heure actuelle
c'est à dire une paupérisation des
retraités nous ne voulons pas ça pour ça
il faut travailler un peu plus mais vous
dites les syndicats sur les responsables
est-ce qu'à force de ne pas bouger là il
c'est la quatrième journée de
mobilisation avec à chaque fois au moins
un million de personnes dans la rue
est-ce qu'à force de ne pas bouger vous
n'entraînez pas bien le fait qu'il monte
d'un cran et et là ils disent ben ça ne
suffit pas de manifester on va passer à
l'étape supérieure mais nous avons bougé
sur plein de plein de points sur la
pénibilité sur l'index senior sur les
20-21 ans vous savez pour qu'il fasse
eux aussi
vous voyez ce que j'ai c'est eux qui
mettent aussi
la condition d'équilibre finalement de
côté quel est l'intérêt de faire une
réforme des retraites si au fond il n'y
a pas d'équilibre notre objectif il est
d'équilibrer les pensions moi je le dis
si nous souhaitions être populaire on ne
ferait pas cette réforme si on l'a fait
c'est que il y a une obligation de la
faire qu'on sera responsable par rapport
à nos pensionnés à l'heure actuelle et
ce à venir si on la fait pas il y aura
plus d'équilibre possible et donc dans
ces cas là on continuera s'endetter puis
un jour ça s'arrêtera et on baissera les
missions
vous vous leur dites vous pouvez
continuer à manifester on ne bougera pas
sur l'âge
nous ce qu'on fait c'est ce que je fais
encore ce matin c'est devenir expliquer
la réforme oui c'est une réforme
d'effort oui demander deux ans de plus
de travail oui ça peut être difficile et
perçu comme étant difficile je le
comprends nous le comprendre mais ce que
ce qu'on ne pourrait pas comprendre
c'est le fait que dans quelques années
les pensions s'écroule parce qu'il y a
plus de même que les pensionnés les
retraités soient n'est pas des retraites
dignes ça on ne l'acceptera pas et donc
ça passe pas les Français disent on a
trouvé l'argent pendant la crise
pourquoi là on le trouve pas c'est ça la
grande difficulté vous avez raison c'est
qu'à un moment au fond on a eu
l'impression qu'il y a de l'argent
magique l'argent magique n'existe plus
nous ne l'avons plus cet argent et nous
ce que nous voulons c'est que les
cotisations payent les pensions comme
dans une sorte de boîte noire qui fasse
que nous n'ayons pas besoin de nous
endetter à chaque fois l'endettement
coûte beaucoup plus cher et un moment ça
veut dire qu'on est dépendant aussi des
créditeurs étrangers dans cet effort
d'explication Elizabeth borne a pris
contact à appeler les syndicats ce
week-end
quel est la marge de manœuvre qu'est-ce
qu'il reste comme marge de manœuvre de
marge de discussion avec les partenaires
sociaux oui nous ce qu'on
oui il y a toujours des il y a toujours
des discussions moi il y a plein de
points sur la pénibilité sur l'index
seniors des choses qu'on a vraiment
travaillé avec la CFDT et sur lesquels
d'ailleurs il ne revendiquent même plus
la paternité on voit bien qu'ils se sont
totalement figés sur les 64 ans qui est
l'objet politique en réalité c'est cet
objet politique et tout le reste les
avancées le minimum de pension vraiment
la bien meilleure reconnaissance de la
pénibilité tout notre travail maintenant
et à venir sur l'emploi senior au fond
les syndicats ont été très partis
prenantes depuis des semaines et non
revendique plus du tout la paternité
mais nous on pense que c'est là l'axe le
plus important sur lesquels ça va
vraiment transformer la vie des gens
parce qu'au fond être Seigneur à partir
de 55 ans et vivre 55 ans d'ailleurs
comment on définit un senior et de vivre
dans l'angoisse de plus avoir d'emploi
et qu'au fond de ne plus être nécessaire
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut qu'on puisse
travailler et avancer nous on a beaucoup
de propositions dessus dans ce texte et
dans le texte suivant qui arrivera plein
emploi dessus en disant
très d'être beaucoup plus dur en disant
par exemple interdire les ruptures
collectives
portées vers les seniors rendre ça
interdit on voit bien qu'il y a y
compris avec les d'ailleurs négociations
que j'ai eu avec les syndicats il y
avait une sorte de complaisance de
chacun l'employeur le syndicat le
salarié qu'au fond à 59 ans on faisait
un plan collectif on allait jusqu'à 62
ans et tout le monde y trouvait son
compte bah ça ça doit s'arrêter ça ça
doit très clairement s'arrêter et donc
comment on fait pour que pour que les
seniors puissent rester dans l'emploi
jusqu'au bout avoir des taux d'emploi
qui sont comparables à nos voisins
européens on est bien en dessous à
l'heure actuelle c'est ça qu'on doit
changer est-ce qu'il faut des sanctions
financières clairement sur l'index
senior alors en fait il y a eu de
discussions possible nous on a fait une
avancée avec mon groupe puisque l'index
senior il est il est obligatoire à
partir de 300 salariés nous ce qu'on
propose dans un des amendements c'est de
le descendre à 50 salariés donc de
toucher PME pourquoi ça veut dire que là
on a 60% des seniors qui à l'heure
actuelle sont actifs donc sont impactés
par cette index senior ça nous semble
plus efficace la contrepartie c'est qu'à
ce moment-là on a une sanction
financière si on ne publie pas l'index
seniors sinon on a une négociation
renforcée comme nous avait demandé à
CFDT obligation de résultats mais
obligation de négociation notre objectif
nous il n'est pas de mettre des amendes
aux entreprises notre objectif c'est
qu'ils emploi des seniors mais quand on
commence à mettre les PME donc de 50
salariés au même niveau de de
réglementation que les beaucoup plus
grosse faut bien comprendre aussi que
une entreprise de 50 salariés et Dieu
sait que je sais ce que c'est
les postes ne sont pas doublés donc vous
avez vous pouvez avoir une stratégie de
recrutement et c'est important de la
mettre en place mais vous avez comment
dire des salariés que vous connaissez
tous par leur prénom organisés on ne
change pas les salariés comme ça donc je
crois que c'est important de ne pas
mettre des sanctions financières sur sur
le l'organigramme de l'entreprise
mais mais mais le mais pour moi ce qui
est important c'est qu'on puisse faire
en sorte de de sensibiliser et
d'orienter la politique pour que les de
chaque entreprise pour que les seniors
puissent rester dans l'emploi sur le
donc ça c'est pour l'index sanction
sanction financière en publication et si
mauvais résultats négociation renforcée
sur le reste évidemment les syndicats
n'attend pas que des compromis sur
l'index senior qu'est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à faire comme autre avancée qui
n'ont pas déjà été avancés puisqu'il y a
encore Olivier Véran et Olivier dussobe
disait qu'ils étaient ouverts à des
modifications de la part des
parlementaires sur quoi vous allez
encore avancer c'est aussi un point qui
est très attendu on espère qu'on pourra
en parler c'est article 9 donc vous
savez qu'on est on est englué dans
l'article 2 au bout d'une semaine
article 9 où on peut peut-être encore
faire des avancées sur la pénibilité ça
ne touche pas assez suffisamment de
monde on aura plus de Français qui vont
rentrer dans le cadre de la pénibilité
nous ce que l'on souhaite c'est que on
puisse avoir des fiches de poste en
fonction des postes occupés mais aussi
un suivi médical plus important qui fait
face en sorte que ceux qui sont usés
puissent partir plus tôt et ça je crois
qu'il faut donner confiance aussi dans
ce système là c'est à dire qu'au fond ce
qui le peuvent et je dis toujours ceux
qui le peuvent travailleront jusqu'à 64
ans ceux qui ne peuvent plus parce
qu'ils sont usés doivent pouvoir
s'arrêter avant il faut que chaque il
faut que chaque salarié chaque salarié
puisse se dire c'est vrai ça marche et
ça on le voit on l'entend et
manifestations au fond ils sont
persuadés que ça ne sera pas pour eux la
retraite c'est quelque chose de très
intime en réalité très intime ça vous ça
touche au plus profond de soi-même et
donc il faut que nous puissions rassurer
expliquer accompagner mais c'est vrai
qu'on sera jugé et c'est ça la
difficulté sur la mise en place de la
réforme et et on a du blocage dans la
rue des des avant le vote ça qui est
compliqué ça veut dire quoi que vous
pouvez pas avancer vous n'avez
l'impression que vous pouvez pas avancer
comme boulot
vous savez je crois fonction par
fonction emploi par jour un problème de
les Français qui manifeste vous pensez
que c'est parce qu'ils ont pas compris
le texte c'est pas qu'ils n'ont pas
compris le texte la stratégie dans
laquelle on veut aller et qu'est-ce que
ça va changer concrètement ils ont très
bien compris le texte vous savez la
seule chose qu'on devait dans une
manifestation la seule chose c'est la
mesure d'âge on ne rentre plus
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de choses de
fake news on a l'impression que ceux qui
devait partir 57 ans maintenant vous
partir 64 enfin c'est on entend plein de
choses différentes oui c'est la mesure
d'âge et vous savez quand nous on a fait
campagne l'élection législative je m'en
souviens très bien moi je suis député de
Paris l'élection législative le point
extrêmement dur pendant cette élection
c'était ça
enfin voilà le point difficile c'était
ça on l'a porté on a perdu beaucoup de
députés aussi on a perdu beaucoup de
députés à 200 300 voix on se doute bien
que le fait de d'avoir pris des
positions sur la retraite comme l'a fait
le président de la République et
nous-mêmes pendant nos campagnes nous a
mis en difficulté mais je crois que
c'est une réforme indispensable nous
savons pas comme eux d'autres membres
comment équilibrer nos comptes et donc
comment sécuriser nos pensions alors
vous parlez des avancées qui sont encore
possibles le texte va arriver au Sénat à
partir de vendredi minutes puisque ça
sera la fin à l'Assemblée et Bruno
Retailleau qui lui soutient la mesure
d'âge en revanche à des propositions à
faire je voudrais savoir si vous êtes
d'accord il veut que les femmes qui ont
3 enfants puissent partir à 63 ans ou à
64 est-ce que vous êtes pour alors ça
c'est pas du c'est pas prévu nous
j'entends j'entends d'ailleurs les les
LR aussi sur une politique nataliste et
favorisée tel ou tel
partie nous on part du principe que
m'envoyer je suis dans nous sommes dans
une mesure d'équilibre l'objectif il est
de faire une réforme pour que les
pensions soient équilibrées objectives
2030 donc on peut lancer non mais
j'entends on peut donner toutes les
mesures toutes les mesures comme ça oui
j'ai une bonne idée la foire aux bonnes
idées moi ce que je voudrais c'est
savoir combien ça coûte c'est vrai c'est
tout simple pourquoi pas on peut
réfléchir à tout
la question c'est combien ça coûte et
donc ça il nous faut aussi un minimum
travailler dessus en tout cas moi je
vais pas les informations venant du
Sénat est-ce qu'ils ont cette
information est-ce qu'ils ont travaillé
dessus savoir ce que ça coûte bon faire
une réforme déjà un tiers des
cotisations supplémentaires du fait du
reportage et redonner dans cette pour
améliorer notre système à l'heure
actuelle le minimum contribue avec tout
ce que vous avez fait comme compromis
depuis le début on n'est plus à 17,7
milliards déjà de gains de réforme mais
il a raison là-dessus il a raison on
demande pas d'ailleurs 17 milliards
c'est l'ensemble des cotisations
supplémentaires qui nous donne 17
milliards mais on un tiers repart dans
l'amélioration des minimum de pension
dans la pénibilité dans le fond
d'investissement pour rendre les postes
moins pas de travail moins difficile il
y a beaucoup d'accompagnement on
améliore vraiment le système à l'heure
actuelle
[Musique]
écoutez c'est plutôt une bonne idée
là-dessus pareil il faut juste regarder
dès qu'on commence à parler de pension
de reversion on a eu aussi et bien il y
a beaucoup d'idées on parlait aussi nous
à l'assemblée du PACS des gens pacsés
comment comment on organise ça pour le
moment la pension de réversion c'est
quelque chose que sur lesquelles on n'a
pas voulu rentrer en disant que si on
commence à rentrer dessus ça va être
compliqué je sais que c'est il porte ça
de façon assez forte je trouve que ça
peut s'entendre en tout cas moi je
trouve que j'ai on étudie à ça avec avec
bienveillance
à l'instant
lui annoncé 36 milliards alors je crois
que c'est des dollars on est pas très
loin la parité 36 milliards de dollars
de résultats en 2002 c'est un résultat
le plus élevé son histoire est-ce que
pour vous c'est pas du pain béni
finalement pour vos opposants des amis
qui vous invite à faire financer cette
réforme des retraites par les
milliardaires alors nous ça va être le
concours vous savez ça va être le
concours dans dans
quelques heures peut-être ou quelques
jours puisque c'est la fin de l'article
2 d'après l'article 2 des impôts et des
taxes vous vous plantez un député
écologiste il pousse une cotisation vous
plantez un député LFI pousse une taxe ça
c'est très clair donc il pose ou un
impôts
ce qui est certain c'est que nous on
part du principe que ceux qui ont entre
les gros énergies énergéticiens pardon
qui ont gagné beaucoup d'argent du fait
de aussi de la crise en
Ukraine en Ukraine la crise en général
doivent contribuer on a voté un
mécanisme européen qui rapporte quand
même beaucoup d'argent qui nous semble
être efficace et qui permet de que les
entreprises n'aient pas
domiciles et du chiffre d'affaires ou
des impôts dans un autre pays en faute
contourne cette imposition
supplémentaire nous on part du principe
de plutôt se réjouir quand tu
l'entreprise française fait beaucoup
beaucoup de bénéfices et plutôt bon
signe c'est à dire qu'elle va employer
qu'elle va pouvoir investir on met pas
tout sur le même plan c'est là que c'est
pas parce qu'une entreprise ou des gens
gagnent bien leur vie que ils sont
forcément des gens pas bien ou à montrer
du doigt nous il y a pas d'adversaire il
y a pas de gens à ostraciser on fait pas
partie des de ceux qui pensent que au
fond si on était tous pauvre ce serait
bien par contre est-ce que total doit
contribuer un peu plus vous savez bien
que on les pousse à à directement
pouvoir faire une remise à la pompe je
pense que ce serait bienvenu de leur
part et vous leur dites qu'il faut qu'il
a parce qu'ils ont évoqué l'idée de
faire cette remise à la pompe je crois
que ce serait bien de le faire je le
redis je pense que ce serait bien de le
faire
tout de suite on voit bien que les
Français ont des grandes difficultés à
l'heure actuelle on a encore un taux
d'inflation important on va mettre en
place le panier des premiers voilà
anti-inflation on passe ça me semblerait
de bonne aloi anti inflation dans 15
jours
dans les jours qui viennent et le
exactement l'annoncera mais mettre une
réduction sur une prime de réduction sur
le carburant de la part de Total me
semblerait le bienvenu on va revenir à
la réforme d'attrape les débats qui
reprennent donc cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle est-ce que vous pensez
pouvoir avancer plus vite que la semaine
dernière ça dépend pas de nous ça dépend
de la nups sur l'index 2 sur l'index
pardon senior article 2 pardon
c'est tout à fait étonnant puisque il
passe leur temps à nous dire que ça sert
à rien que c'est nul que ça fonctionnera
jamais mais ils ont déposé 1612
amendements vous voyez c'est ça
l'obstruction et donc ils ne font que
parler de ça et en commission on a passé
deux jours à parler ça tout en disant on
va amener ils veulent essayer ils nous
disent on veut améliorer quelque chose
auquel on ne croit pas donc on leur dit
enlever vos amendements vous n'y croyez
pas bah on va voter et on va aller
jusqu'à l'article 7 et voter la loi
arrêtons de faire l'obstruction pour
l'option moi je ça dépend de si ils
maintiennent tous leurs amendements on
ne peut pas y arriver si ils enlèvent
leurs amendements comme on leur demande
comme tout le monde leur demande on va y
arriver
la majorité et le groupe Renaissance il
souhaite voter la loi avant vendredi ou
vendredi soir nous on veut voter la loi
on veut voter l'article 7 mais on veut
voter tous les articles on veut voter
l'article 9 sur la pénibilité on veut
voter aussi le minimum contributif c'est
les minimum de pension de réévaluer les
minimum de pension je pense que c'est ça
que les Français attendent ça tendent
pas ce qu'on passe 4 jours sur l'index
seniors même si c'est important vous
voyez c'est un moment c'est la
responsabilité de la France insoumise
principalement de faire en sorte de dire
non le débat doit avoir lieu et en fait
ils ont peur du vote ils ont qu'une peur
c'est le vote parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
le perdront donc comme ils ont peur ils
préfèrent faire le le jeu du au fond on
n'a jamais choisi démocratiquement
est-ce que devoir aller au 49,3 serait
de votre point de vue un échec du
parlementarisme à la française
pour il y a une majorité pour voter à
l'assemblée cette réforme des retraites
je suis tout le temps dans l'hémicycle
on a passé des centaines des centaines
d'amendements on a passé déjà un article
on a toujours une majorité on n'a pas
perdu un amendement on n'a pas perdu un
article on est tout le temps majoritaire
donc je n'ai aucune inquiétude la
majorité s'est engagé et sur ce projet
au moment de l'élection et les
républicains l'ont toujours dit voilà
notre objectif
il ne manquera pas une voix
l'ensemble des députés Renaissance
voteront évidemment la réforme des
retraites c'est un engagement
présidentiel
oui mais bonjour ils vont revenir c'est
aussi le rôle du député c'est aussi de
pousser de travailler d'avancer mais
l'ensemble des députés Renaissance et je
vous le dis je vous le redis votre rond
évidemment cette réforme
ce que vous avez très affirmatif Aurore
berger disait la même chose que vous
hier on aura une majorité on aura une
majorité c'est pas un peu la méthode
Coué bah écoutez il y a 8 mois vous êtes
campagne pour du 65 ans ici au Sénat on
est on est au Sénat ont toujours dit que
porter un amendement il a encore voté il
y a quelques semaines en 64 ans avec une
accélération la loi Touraine c'est que
exactement ce que nous faisons sauf que
en plus on met des mesures sociales
quand même importantes de pénibilité
de de d'accès à un minimum de pension un
peu plus important revalorise les toutes
petites pensions donc je crois que le
Sénat israélit extrêmement favorable et
je vois pas comment les républicains ne
pourrait ne pas voter contre puis on a
eu les engagements de on est des
engagements d'aussi d'ericsiotiques je
crois qu'il a dit public bon et
plusieurs fois que pour lui c'était
important d'avoir des retraites et
équilibré au fond leur message politique
depuis des années serait
incompréhensible pour leurs électeurs si
parce que c'était Emmanuel Macron qui
l'apportait il l'a votait pas une
dernière question là-dessus Jean-Claude
Mahy qui était à votre place vendredi
évoque un risque de boomerang dans les
urnes si cette réforme passe et si elle
passe en force j'offre route des yeux ce
matin dans Le Figaro rappelle que dans
les pays qui ont rallongé l'âge ça s'est
traduit par des élections perdues
quelques années plus tard Joffre de
Bézieux qui soutient la réforme est-ce
qu'il faut craindre une nouvelle poussée
du vote extrémiste c'est ça le courage
politique vous savez c'est de tenir ses
promesses on a fait cette promesse j'ai
fait cette promesse bois mes électeurs à
Paris le président de la République a
fait cette promesse de de faire en sorte
que les pensions soient restent des
pensions élevées par rapport aux
homologues européens mais vous savez ça
amène des examens de pas tenir ses
promesses c'est ça qui amène au fait
qu'on est on est battu la fois d'après
tenir ses promesses être courageux tenir
sa ligne moi je crois que c'est la
meilleure chose qui puisse arriver c'est
le président de la République a été élu
et pourtant on a toujours dit avant oui
c'est impossible au fond
les Français aiment zapper non je crois
que les un moment on est face quand on
est dans une élection on est face à un
choix et que le choix on se souvient
aussi ce contenu leur promesse nous
évoquez votre terre d'élection qui est
Paris il n'y a pas une rupture entre
Paris et la province et les
sous-préfectures pour reprendre
l'expression la révolte des soupes
préfectures oui je crois ça fait partie
des choses qu'on regarde beaucoup il y a
une vraie mobilisation importante dans
les dans les villes les villes moyennes
les sous-préfectures comme vous dites
qui
en fait qui rappelle d'autres choses je
pense que au-delà de du départ plus tard
il y a parfois un mal-être un livre une
sentiment que les services publics ne
sont plus assez présents et c'est
sûrement vrai on a on améliore les
choses plein de choses sur la santé sur
sur l'accès au service public mais il
est ressenti encore et probablement avec
justesse pas assez efficace et donc je
pense qu'il y a toute cette angoisse de
fond du déclassement qui s'in
principalement dans les villes moyennes
donc vous avez raison là-dessus il y a
un vrai c'est pas le même paradigme à
Paris Kaya
oui une question d'actualité liée au
drame survenu en Seine-et-Marne ce
week-end l'accident de la route pierre
Palma impliquée et surtout les
stupéfiants impliqués la banalisation
des stupéfiants toutes catégories
confondues dans les accidents de la
circulation interpellent beaucoup de
spécialistes s'expriment d'ailleurs
depuis 48 heures sur le sujet elle sera
à l'origine de 700 morts sur les routes
est-ce que dans ce contexte notamment
sur la question du cannabis ça fait
partie des statistiques est-ce que il
faut les réaliser aller plus loin dans
la localisation du cannabis ou au
contraire est-ce qu'il faut durcir même
imposition elle est très claire je ne
veux absolument pas de légalisation du
cannabis c'est très simple vraiment
c'est la ligne je suis sur la ligne de
Gérald Darmanin il y a pour moi c'est
les drogues doivent être interdites
continuent à être interdite et on doit
continuer à faire
expliquer le dangerosité hier soir
j'imagine
tous ceux qui au fond se disent ben
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup poussé sur
l'alcool attention chacun d'entre nous
sait que au bout de verre ça passe plus
on peut plus conduire sur le la cocaïne
et comme c'est interdit ou le cannabis
comme c'est un dernier en fait on a
aucune communication dessus au fond
c'est un nom dit je crois que aussi il
va falloir qu'on puisse communiquer un
peu plus et dans dans la réalité si si
le nombre des que vous dites et
d'ailleurs est un nombre vrai de gens
qui qui conduisent sous l'emprise du
cannabis et de l'alcool sous l'emprise
du cannabis et de la cocaïne ou des
drogues dures est aussi important que ce
que on pense et ce qui est constaté il
va falloir que on puisse aussi nous y
répondre il répondent peut-être en
interpellant beaucoup plus les uns et
les autres sur la responsabilité et vous
savez ce qui est ce qui est arrivé à
pied Palmade je pense que beaucoup nous
l'entendons tous en disant il a
probablement foutu en l'air la vie il a
de toute une famille il a foutu
probablement sa vie à lui et donc voilà
chacun prend ses responsabilités je
crois que ça va être peut-être un
tournant par rapport à la cocaïne sur en
haut de l'alcool la drogue dure et la
conduite quand je l'espère merci Sylvain
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
merci Fabrice son va reparler de la
réforme des retraites tout de suite dans
le club